[Music]
in 1948 the historian Arthur
Schlessinger asked fellow historians to
rate u.s. presidents the poster soon
followed suit they've been asking
Americans to assess presidents ever
since Barack Obama leaves office was a
solid approval rating he's in the mid
fifties in most polls but when it comes
to job performance the verdict is mixed
President Obama inherited a terrible
economy although American sees some
improvement after eight years only a
bare majority of who the job is doing
here
less than half approve of the job that
he's doing handling terrorism with
foreign policy generally 61 percent
believe that the u.s. is less respected
than in the past as for Obamacare fuse
about the law have generally been more
negative than positive since its passage
solid majority disapprove of the way the
president has handled the issue however
only 35 percent favor straight repeal
finally two-thirds and a puker race a
race relations have gotten nervous since
2008 only nine percent say they've
gotten better
first revs of history are always subject
to revision at this point we know that
President Obama is personally more
popular than policies to learn more
about my take on Obama's legacy check
the links in the description below also
let us know what other topics you'd like
AI scholars to cover in 60 seconds
[Music]